we should uh we should get started so
you know um
uh
let me just say that um you know we had
a we had a couple of um uh
colloquial last last semester which were
roughly on this topic of
of how do you architect
um
you know fault tolerant qubits so we had
a we had a colloquium by michelle
deborah from yale uh on a bosonic air
correction and
from patrick hayden on on uh
architecting a fault tolerant qubit
and so you know i view this uh this
colloquium today by jeff thompson in the
in the same spirit of continuing this
exploration
and um
uh so i should say by way of
introduction that jeff is um
he um he got his phd with uh with misha
luken and he actually did his post talk
there at mit and and harvard as well
he works on experimental atomic physics
and he's he's a currently
uh professor in uh electrical engine and
computer engineering at princeton
but but um
[Music]
you know i think he's been thinking in
in a very interesting innovative
direction about how you might uh
how you might
you know do error correction more
robustly in
in atomic systems we are converting
general errors to to erasure errors so
i'm really looking forward to this talk
it should be quite exciting so jeff uh
just turn it over to you
great thank you very much
um
just get my screen sharing going
um
all right
um so um it's a real pleasure for me to
be here and i'm very grateful to umesh
for the invitation um
let me you know say at the outset that
you know i'm an experimentalist and uh i
normally give a talk that focuses on our
experimental work but we have this
um this kind of more theoretical result
uh recently that uh that i think is
interesting and is guiding the
experiments we're doing now and and um
you know really encouraged me to focus
this talk on that so it's a little bit
out of my comfort um talking you know
mostly about theory i'll discuss the how
exactly we're going to implement this in
our experiments and a little bit of
background there towards the end of my
talk um but but you know as a
consequence i'll i'll probably say some
things that are i'll probably say a lot
of things are very obvious i'll probably
say some things that are wrong and i
would i would love for for you know
which ideas are which to be a topic of
discussion at the end
um
but but an overview of what i'll what
i'll tell you about um is you know
basically start with the you know the
claim that engineering qubits physical
qubits with favorable noise models um
can lead to significant improvements and
you know either like the fault tolerance
threshold or the overhead that you would
need to do fault tolerant quantum
computing and this is something people
have been thinking about for a while in
a variety of contexts um in this talk
what i'll tell you about is a
kind of a way of engineering a noise
model for neutral atom qubits which are
i would say an up and coming but you
know very exciting uh qubit platform um
that converts the dominant errors um
into erasure errors which i'll argue are
very favorable in terms of the threshold
and overhead
i think this is probably i'll sort of
belabor the definition of erasure error
and why it's beneficial because i think
probably these ideas can be extended to
other qubit systems we haven't exactly
done that yet um and so for most of my
talk i'll be talking about this theory
work in this paper here um which i want
to you know emphasize was a really fun
and unique collaboration with uh with
shruti puri and her student yue wu at
gail um you know experts in air
correction and and with another
experimental election on kolkoz who also
sort of you know was moonlighting as a
theorist with me on this but it was
really you know this is really a unique
collaboration to actually think be able
to think sort of deeply about you know
what happens on the atomic physics side
when errors occur but also what the
consequences would be on the error
correction side
so um so i would i guess kind of
describe in a nutshell what we're trying
to do is cheat to win an error
correction you know there's many many uh
uh you know for a long time thought
about the thresholds and things like
that for error correction in terms of a
very idealized and well but maybe not
ideal but the abstract model of errors
which is just depolarizing so x y and z
are you know equally likely and act on
the qubits in an independently random
way
um but if you have a simpler noise model
than that you can have much higher
thresholds that are advantageous and i
think probably the most discussed
example of this is biased noise where
for example say z errors are much more
likely than x or wires
um and this this case has been pretty
well studied and kind of the uh a good
code that you can use to take advantage
of this is something called the tailored
surface code um and it's been uh studied
um that the for at least in the kind of
quantum memory context the threshold can
actually be very high in fact in case of
infinite bias the threshold would be 50
if you have this bias noise where it's
only 18 or so if you don't have any bias
if these are independent
um
uh but there's actually two kinds of
threshold that are relevant for when we
talk about codes and computing the first
is what i'll call this quantum memory
threshold where you imagine you have a
code word with no errors and then you
sprinkle some errors in and you get to
do perfect you know syndrome
measurements and decoding operations so
this uh you know it's
with this kind of quantum memory
threshold the surface code threshold for
unbiased noise mwpm is usually stated as
11 maybe ideally it's 18
but it's in this context that you get
this 50 for bias noise
but what is actually more relevant for
for a real world quantum computation but
a little bit harder to compute is what's
called the circuit level threshold where
instead of just considering errors
sprinkled into an ideal system that you
have to then correct with ideal
operations you actually consider the
circuit itself that you need to go and
measure these operations and and you
know infer what errors happen and then
implement the corrections and annoys
and the circuit level thresholds are
probably always lower than these ideal
memory thresholds and for example for
the surface code the standard surface
code with with unbiased noise this uh
circuit level threshold is around one
percent it's quite a bit lower but it's
the circuit level threshold that's
really the thing that's relevant for for
fault tolerance on computing or lab
because it's actually you know noisy
operations are actually the real world
case that we have
um and actually extending bias noise to
the circuit level um is a little bit
tricky so there's a lot of physical
qubits that naturally have a bias
towards one type of error or another
the rate of bit flips and phase flips is
often described as t1 and t2 for qubits
and those those are not necessarily the
same most stupid systems
um but once you consider a circuit
where you put all these elements all
these operations in those those gate
operations um actually mix up the rs
they convert zeros into x errors and
vice versa and so that undoes the bias
at a circuit level
um so to maintain bias at the circuit
level the you know the the
one thing that that helps you do it is
if you have something called a bias
preserving gate which is essentially a
native gate that um that maintains the
you know maintains the noise bias um
and uh and one really well known example
of this and i would argue the only one
that's been really extensively studied
at the circuit level is these kind of
cat qubits like the kerkat qubit for
example um uh which my collaborators
should purify gail um did a lot of
pioneering work in um and with these
kinds of qubits it's you know it's
there's a a technique that they propose
in this paper for actually implementing
a bias preserving c not gate that
maintains the z bias of the noise even
through the c not gate and with that
they're able to get an increase in the
uh
in the circuit level threshold compared
to the case that you you know you don't
have uh
uh you don't have this bias noise or you
don't use bias disturbing kids
um and uh and this increase in threshold
then means that for a given physical
error rate you obviously have much lower
logical areas but even though we know of
a lot of qubits that have this bias
noise we actually don't know of many
where where you can
where you can maintain that advantage at
the circuit level
so another way that you can cheat
another type of
noise model that's more favorable than
just depolarizing errors um is erasure
errors and by way of explaining what
this uh you know what this is let me say
that in general the reason you get an
improvement from these simplified noise
models is that you reduce when it comes
time to decode what errors have occurred
you reduce the space of possibilities
that the decoder has to distinguish
between and so if i had five qubits and
sort of generic to polarizing noise i
have 15 errors i have to distinguish if
i have bias noise where i really only
have zeros with any probability then i
reduce the space to just five errors but
actually if i have uh
uh
the error if i somehow know
independently for my syndrome
measurement that it was qubit number two
that had the error
then i've reduced it now to three
possibilities i have to fix the error on
that qubit to detect which which one it
was but but i've reduced the space of
possibilities a little bit and so when
the when we know the location of an
error and can use it to facilitate
decoding that's what's meant by an
erasure error that's the essence of an
erasure error
um
erasure errors are actually pretty
common like classically for example you
know bad handwriting you don't often
read uh somebody tries to write an a you
don't often read it as a j but instead
you just say i can't read what that
letter is
um and it's also actually erasure has
been pretty well studied in the quantum
context in the context of
of photonic cubits because if i have a
photon encoded for example a qubit
encoded for example in the polarization
state or path of the photon then uh i
might expect to click in this detector
if it's you know the b state it click in
this detector if it's h but if i don't
get any clicks then that is a
third measurement outcome um
that's an erasure tells you there's an
error on that qubit
and so because of this interest in
photons
thresholds have been studied for erasure
errors and actually the surface code
also as upon a memory gives you a 50
threshold uh
in the case that you have pure erasure
errors studied 10 years ago
um
so um
another way to understand why why these
erasure errors are more beneficial is
that actually you just get a larger code
distance for the same so in the
depolarizing channel if i consider this
repetition code
um
you know this distance three repetition
code i can detect up to two errors but
only correct one of them using majority
vote but if i have this erasure error
where instead of zero flipping to one
both zero and one become some other
error state and these actually air
states don't even have to be the same
um
then then i can actually detect in a
distance three code up to three errors
um and i can correct up to two of them
and so it's actually generic property of
any code quantum or classical impact
that you can correct twice as many
erasure errors as depolarizing nerves
so this this you know if we could
engineer physical qubits that would have
a sort of a bias towards erasure type
errors instead of depolarizing the ears
we would expect them to be
significantly easier to correct
so the context in which i'm going to
discuss this is is neutral atom cubits
um
and um and in atom qubits and this also
applies to ions um you know to first
order there aren't errors right these
are these are basically non-interacting
you know perfect particles that sit
floating in an ultra high vacuum chamber
and the qubits might be encoded in say
the spin two different spin level
sublevels of the electronic ground state
and for
to to reasonable approximation these
states can have essentially infinite
coherence time but um but the challenge
is that they don't in that state where
they have this infinite coherence time
they also don't interact with each other
so there's no two cubic gates you know
going on
um and this is a classic trade-off with
cubits you have non-interacting qubits
that live forever but then you can't do
gates or you have strongly interacting
qubits but then they decoy here around
so the sort of the thing that makes
atoms and ions work really well
then for quantum computing is that what
you can do is use the fact that there's
more than just two levels in this atom
and you can transiently couple the qubit
to some other degree of freedom that is
strongly interacting and use that
coupling transitly to implement a two
cubic gate and then turn it off when
you're done
um so in the case of uh of trapped ions
this sort of degree of freedom that you
coupled to transiently is the motion the
collective motion of the ion chains the
xerox solar gate
and in neutral atoms this degree of
freedom that you couple to transitly is
a highly excited state called a rydberg
state
that's very strongly interacted and i'll
talk more about that on the next slide
but the challenge is that this other
degree of freedom
is typically you know by virtue of being
strongly interacting typically a lot
more sensitive to environmental noise
and therefore much less coherent and so
it gives rise to errors so the way
errors come up crop up mainly in these
atom and ion qubits is actually during a
two cubic gate when you transiently
couple to this you know much noisier
degree
and uh and a consequence of this is that
if you look at you know properties of
atoms and ion qubits you'll see that the
two cubic gate error rate is typically a
hundred to a thousand times worse than
single cubit errors
um so this is really the fundamental
limitation
that's not to say that this is the only
limitation and actually a lot of you
know when it comes down to building
these things uh there's a lot of other
sources of error like urinarys
addressing you know crosstalk errors
things like that but but this i think
what i say here is sort of true about
the fundamental limitations
um
so i wanna at this point explain just a
little bit to you about the rydberg
states that give rise to interactions
that let us implement two big gates
because it's correcting errors from
these red burn states that's going to be
the key idea
so
uh the the you know the energy levels of
an atom um you know kind of no matter
what out of it is basically look like
this they're far apart near the bottom
and then they get really close together
as you get to very high principal
quantum number states again
and so our qubits are encoded down here
but these very high highly excited
states are called red bird states and
they have some universal properties that
are important the first is that the size
of the electron wave function gets
really big so the ground state might be
this big but uh you know n equals 50
which is not even a very big principle
quantum number for us state um you know
is orders of magnitude bigger these can
be almost micron size wave functions
um and because these wave functions are
so big they're very polarizable sort of
fluffy and so that gives rise to a van
der waals interaction where if two of
these atoms are close to each other they
have an interaction whose strength rose
is the twelfth power of the principal
quantum number so if you go from n
equals five to fifty you really switch
on a very you know almost pathologically
strong interaction
and the lifetime of these states is is
not very long but gets longer as you go
so all of these things are are favorable
for implementing case and to give you
kind of a sense of scale if you have
atoms that are a few you know few 10
microns apart in a pretty high principal
quantum number state you can have
interactions that are ordered hundreds
of megahertz and lifetimes that are
hundreds of seconds so there's a
favorable you know favorable conditions
for implementing high fidelity gates
um
so the way that we use um this
interaction to implement a gate is by
coupling our qubit state into the
rydberg state so i have these two ground
states where i might store a qubit you
know it could be the atom could be zero
state might be spin down or the one
states spin up but then if i couple one
of these states spin up to the rydberg
state i can do something like do a two
pi pulse and pick up a you know
a minus one and that that would let me
do a single qubit okay but then if i
have two atoms i have to consider their
collective dynamics so if neither of
them if they're both in the zero state
nothing happens if only one of them is
in the one state then i can do a robbie
oscillation like this just as if i had a
single atom but if they're both in the
one state then i'm trying to excite them
both simultaneously to the rydberg state
but the challenge is that i can't do
that actually because the doubly excited
state because of this very strong
rydberg interaction this river blockade
is shifted way out of resonance with my
driving laser if this shift is much
larger than my gravity
so then i won't actually do a robbie
oscillation all the way up here i'll
just have this constrained dynamics
coupling from one one to the symmetric w
state and that'll happen with a
different problem frequency
so because the speed of my dynamics is
different zero omega and two omega in
these different computational states i
can pick the right kind of pulse
uh to implement a cz gate um essentially
using these different dynamics um
and uh and that's the basis of the
ribber blockade game that's how this
interaction is used to implement an
effective two cubic gate between the
ground state spins
but the fundamental source of error the
challenge that we have to deal with is
that this redwood state has a long but
not infinite lifetime it may be a couple
hundred microseconds and so during the
time that it takes me to do this gate it
has some probability of decay and that's
going to give an error
and for kind of current parameters
for these gates this is at the level of
a you know one to a few percent error
per two cubic gate um but an optimistic
projection of where we could get by
making these lasers faster and so on is
maybe to about a tenth of a percent
um but this is the sort of the
fundamental limitation to the fidelity
now the thing that's nice about
atomic cubits though is that you know
work we've uh as a
civilization we're very good at atomic
business we've been doing it for a long
time and so we really understand the
physics of these things exactly and also
the physics of the air model exactly so
so by thinking about what energy levels
we use we have some ability to shape and
control what happens when these red bird
states decay the conceptually simplest
model to set up would be one where when
this rivering state decays it can come
back down to either the zero state or
the one state um and in that case that
would implement uh that would just give
you a depolarizing error every time you
had this decay
um a cleverer thing that you could do
would actually be to choose your spin
states here zero and one such that um
maybe angular momentum selection rules
forbid the decay from r down to zero and
so r is only allowed to decay to one and
in that case you would actually have a
better error model than this
depolarizing error because it would be
biased
um
and and the sort of reduction of these
rydberg decay errors to biased errors is
actually the basis of a very i think you
know important for us uh
important to
set up how we thought about this problem
paper from miesha lieutenant's group on
on engineering air models and kind of
achievements
um
so
the but kind of the key idea of our work
then um is is to try to take this
engineering one step further and instead
of
using um and actually what we do instead
of encoding two bits in the ground state
we encode them in sub-levels of a
meta-stable state a state that doesn't
have an infinite lifetime like the
ground state but still has a very very
long lifetime you know it can be seconds
of practice um
but if we pick the right meta-stable
state then we can have the property that
when we excite to the rydberg state if
the rydberg state decays those decays
overwhelmingly actually do not come back
to this meta-stable state but they go
down to the true ground state because in
general that's where you know atoms want
to go when they decay and i guess that
statement you know that's what atoms
want to do is not in line with the level
of sophistication that you know i claim
we have understanding these atomic
systems but but um
but it wants to go back to the to the
real ground state
and um and so if we then have a way to
detect population that has fallen down
into this ground state and to do it in a
way that doesn't disturb the qubits that
are left up here then we've basically
converted these rydberg decays into
erasure
um and i want to point out that um
there's a actually a very analogous
concept was proposed
in uh in trapped ions by wes campbell in
this this very nice paper
um so
if we want to propose sort of a physical
system and which to implement this there
are two
questions that are really critical the
first question is you know what fraction
of the errors actually become a racist
like this what fraction can you detect
um
this is equivalent to sort of asking
what the magnitude of the noise bias is
for for biased polynomial errors
and then the second question is you know
can you actually detect them efficiently
without disturbing the other cubits if
when you try to measure whether there
were any erasures you have some
probability of inducing arizona all
these other cubits that didn't have
errors which is hopefully most of them
this might not actually be beneficial
so the central result of our work is to
kind of think very carefully about the
level structure of a specific atom
ytterbium
and to
show with sort of detailed atomic
physics calculations that using the sort
of triple p0 metastable state we can
probably get to about a 98 percent
fraction of errors converted into a
ratio so it's a very large bias towards
erasures and detect these uh erasures in
a way that has negligible back action
onto the rest of the cube it's a very
efficient detection
um
so in the kind of this you know the rest
of this theory part of my talk i'm going
to explain how
i'm going to take this result as a given
and explain to you what the benefits are
and then in the the last half of my talk
i will actually talk more about the
specific atomic physics of ytterbium and
how it is that we're able to do this
um
the picture that i have in my head
actually for um for these sort of using
these metastable qubits to detect errors
um is always somebody walking on a
tightrope and and this i guess starts
from a notion that maybe a quantum
computation is a little bit like your
qubits are a little bit like dancers
they're doing a dance uh the dance is
very intricate uh they have to do all
the moves exactly right um but the you
know the challenge with eric wretch is
that you're actually not allowed to
watch them do this dance you just have
to look at where they are you know at
the beginning and where they are at the
end of the dance and infer whether they
did all the dance steps correctly in the
middle
so the notion of using this metastable
state is somehow instead to ask these
dancers to do their dance on a tightrope
you know way up 100 feet in the air and
the benefit of doing it this way is you
don't actually have to watch the dancers
to know that they're doing the dance uh
correctly all you have to do is look at
the ground underneath the tightrope um
and observe if any dancers are falling
down um and uh and
and uh and actually you don't even
necessarily have to watch in real time
you can just come periodically and check
to see whether whether any any errors
occur so by making the system sort of
very unstable
very fragile you uh
you sort of make these areas easier to
detect
so in our work with um with ua and
shimon and truthy we you know we have
this atomic physics model and then the
question is how do you actually
incorporate this into a circuit to see
if you really get a circuit level
advantage from duties and so we consider
this specifically in the context of the
xczx surface code um and with the sort
of the simplified error model which i'll
discuss extensions to at the end um
where we assume there's only errors on
two cubic gates because those are those
are dominant for these atomic platforms
um and we say every time you do a two
cubic gate there's a poly error with
probability pp
uh and an erasure error with probability
p e and then the the parameter um that
sort of governs how well this works is
the erasure fraction which is the
fraction of all the errors that are that
are irrational
and so in the circuit that measures the
stabilizers there's a series of two
cubic gates and after every two cubic
gate you you know we illuminate the
array uh um with some light that would
give off some fluorescence photons if
any atoms had fallen down to the ground
it had these are racial errors
um and and that
although it's obviously not included to
be stabilizer simulations it's important
that this is fast and you could do it in
parallel across the array but there's
that's true for our scheme and so then
you know most of the time hopefully
there's no error but then when there is
an error we use uh we use a sort of a
movable optical tweezer to replace atoms
from a reservoir
and what this
does is it converts this you know this
error that happened here and this atom
has actually been lost probably during
our detection process but but we know
there was an error there and we replace
it with an atom so this atom still with
respect to the code it still has an
error at some random state and then
we're going to use subsequent stabilizer
measurements to sort of project it onto
a specific error and correct it um but
but the important part is that because
we saw this thing happen here and we
know which atom we replaced we know the
location in the circuit of this error
that we have to correct
and and the way
so then in the circuit level simulation
we have to incorporate this information
about where the errors are
into the decoder
um
and uh and this is conceptually pretty
straightforward using the kind of
matching decoders that you use for the
surface code so
for normal depolarizing errors you know
if i have a string of say bit flip
errors then then when i do my stabilizer
measurements i'm going to have two
stabilizers at the end of that chain
light up and then the job of the
matching decoder is to pair these up and
infer okay there is a string of flip
arrows in between there and if these
errors happen near the boundary then i
can you know pair to the boundary tube
because the boundary uh
qubits only have one stabilizer um but
but where the logical errors come from
the lowest weight thing that gives rise
to a logical error is that if i have a
string of bit slits that go you know
halfway or more across my uh across my
code then for the matching decoder it's
actually fundamentally unclear whether
it should kind of connect this to the
left or to the right and if it does it
the wrong way there's going to be a
logic there
so with this erasure model because i i
saw you know at some point during my
circuit evolution i saw aha qubit 4 and
qubit 9 and 273 lit up um i already kind
of know which
qubits are have errors so this makes the
job of the matching decoder a lot easier
because if i now have this sort of d
over two set of errors it kind of
has some reason to believe that the
qubits on this side all it's what i'm
this glowing orb is supposed to mean
that i i knew that there was an error
there it knows which way to match it and
in fact not only can it do d over two
but it can do d minus one um
uh errors and they don't actually all
have to be erasures if there's some
errors that were sort of depolarizing
errors that i didn't see in there um the
knowing some amount of location
information still lets me disintegrate
so it's actually very natural and
straightforward to incorporate this
information into the uh
into the decoder which is actually done
by adjusting the weights in the decoding
graph based on the locations of errors
so in our simulations which we actually
did using the the union fine decoder um
uh we find uh the following that for
this noise model of two cubic gates for
purity polarizing errors you get a
threshold little under one percent which
is sort of standard surface code number
but then by converting 98 of these
errors into a ratio so the threshold
goes up by a factor of 4.4
um to 4 so this is a very significant
increase in the threshold which you can
is sort of a benefit that you can spend
in two ways so to speak you can either
say for you know the same code distance
and same physical error rate i now have
you know many orders of magnitude lower
logical error probability or if i have a
target uh say logical error rate i can
achieve that for the same physical error
rate with a much smaller code so say you
know factor 4 back from 16 in the number
of qubits that you need to use to reduce
the overhead
um
i think actually the other benefit that
maybe is um
the other threshold that changes that
might even be more important for
near-term work is is i think we also
talk about a a pseudo threshold where
which is the threshold where your
logical qubit performs better than just
a single physical cubit if you try to
use so this line here is the pl equals p
and actually this this increases by a
factor of 23 for for a small code so so
this um
big increase in the pseudo threshold may
actually be really important for just
near-term demonstrations of you know an
advantage with fault tolerant operation
of a logical in the first place
um
so in order to get this big gain though
you need to actually convert a pretty
large fraction of your errors into
erasure errors um and we sort of looked
at the threshold as a function of that
fraction um you know we think we can get
up here but um but but there's the whole
curve um
the in in the limit did you have pure
ratio as you get to about 5.1 percent or
something so that's the saturated level
this is a kind of similar to the curve
that we saw for for biased poly errors
um and you can think of you know you can
think of an ada sort of just like the
bias you know px over pz over px um has
sort of uh related to this ratio
fraction like this and and the behavior
of this curve is actually pretty similar
to biased polynomials where you get
about half the gain that you're going to
get in threshold once this bias is 10 or
90 here and by the time you get to a
bias of 100 which is 99 here you've
gotten you know most of the benefit that
you're going to get
um
i'll point out that within the same
model um and assuming bias preserving
gates we looked at uh
we looked at bias noise and this this
ratio the threshold you would get in in
assuming only two cubic gators and the x
easy x code for infinite bias is about
3.7 so so this erasure conversion
performs comparably well and maybe even
a little bit better if this box is
really large
um
in addition to getting this larger
threshold there's another benefit which
is that you get a faster sub threshold
decrease in the logical curve rate so
the logical error rate below the
threshold in a code is is related to p
over the threshold and then to an
exponent which is the
sometimes called the error distance it's
the number of errors that the code can
decode um
and uh and if we if we fix a code
distance here d equals five
and increase this erasure fraction what
you see is that these lines get uh
steeper basically the error rate
decreases faster below the threshold and
if we renormalize everything so you can
just look at slopes you see that it
actually smoothly goes from from
an exponent of three to an exponent
um and and then just extracting these
exponents you you can plot that right
here so also if you have a very high
erasure fraction not only do you have a
much higher threshold but you also have
this faster sub-threshold sequence um so
these are two kind of you know distinct
and complementary benefits
i will point out that as long as the
serrature fraction is finite there is
some regime of sufficiently low error
probability where you kind of go back to
be dominating by the depolarizing
dominated by the the small fraction of
depolarizing or poly errors that are
left and the slope does go back to d
over two but you can't see it in this
plot it's at quite quite a low
quite a low physical error
but this the steeper slope doesn't
continue forever
um so that's the end of i guess the
first part of my talk discussing
basically the you know the
uh i guess why why you would want to do
this um what i uh
have tried to explain is that this
erasure dominated noise model can give
you actually a high circuit level
advantage um with the surface code
that's comparable to or better than what
you can get with uh with bias noise um i
think one question that is interesting
is whether this is generic to other
codes uh or just special to the service
code the fact that codes have a larger
distance for ratio errors is actually
generic property of code so one would
expect this is true so i know people are
really excited about things like ldcp ld
pc codes and stuff like that these days
i i wonder if this could give a benefit
for thresholds in that model as well
another thing that we have thought about
a little bit but not discussed it's not
considered extensively is that the fact
that you know you could also describe
this erasure error as a
gate with heralded errors and in that
case if you think about like you know
resource or like magic state preparation
and fault tolerant quantum computing
where you say prepare many noisy copies
of a resource state and then distill out
a better one
having a large
bias towards erasure errors which is the
same thing as saying you can herald a
lot of the errors may actually allow you
to do some kind of pre-distillation
where you throw out copies of the state
that had errors before you actually try
to distill them and
uh
this this might also give you a
significant reduction in the overhead
that you need for for for doing
universal fault
because this resource state preparation
is a very large fraction of the qubits
involved in in a computation in uh you
know these kind of resource estimates
that people have done for short
algorithm or things like that in the
practical regime
um
so um so in the
in the next part of my talk then what
i'll do is
dive a little bit deeper into the
physics of neutral atom quantum
computing and also introduce that topic
in general a little bit and then how you
know how we use kind of a specific
encoding in a terbium to get to get this
error model with a large bias towards
ratio errors
so um neutral atom quantum computing um
you know in the kind of schematic
diagram that you need to have in a
nutshell is that uh
there's a ultra high vacuum chamber
where an array of sort of tightly
focused laser beams called optical
tweezers holds an array of atoms um and
each atom is one qubit you know encoded
in the spin as we previously discussed
um
you can uh you
measure these atoms by using
fluorescence on a camera you control
gates and the execution of the circuit
using light by focusing down laser beams
that drive particular transitions in the
atom uh onto this array and then um the
interactions between the atoms are
realized using using these highly
excited states called called redbird
states but when they're in the ground
state they're very known there
this field has i think you know really
taken off in the last couple of years
there's now
at least 25 academic groups and i'd put
25 plus here because i i got tired of
counting but i i it could it could even
be a larger number than this and also
you know really exciting for me is is
four companies at least working in this
area including you know quantum adam
computing clara and pascal
um
and uh one of the things that's really
exciting about this this neutral atom
technology is that it kind of comes with
at least some first level of scale built
into it you know we sort of it's already
pretty clear how to make pretty big
arrays of qubits this is from misha
lukens group a 16 by 16 array of atoms
256 cubits and the technology for going
even
you know an order of magnitude or so
higher than this is already pretty clear
because there's this just using
photonics for the addressing and control
really gives you a lot of
parallel kind of control built in it's a
little bit different from
superconducting qubits for example where
you you know two thousand qubits means
two thousand or four thousand or six
thousand wires
for example
um
so um yeah so there's a couple of key
ingredients that go into this neutral
atom computing one is that you know you
can actually not only make sort of
arbitrary arrays of traps but also move
them around in real time and this is
used to create you know defect freeze
arrays as the starting point um for
these computations which you can do in
1d 2d or even 3d but the fact that you
can move these atoms around is also
important for um
for what uh for for this you know step
in our erasure protocol where you need
to replace lost apps by moving new atoms
um
so i already mentioned the properties of
these redbird states um so i'll just
remind you briefly that these highly
excited states give you these strong
interactions um and the way in which we
normally talk about this interactions is
the rydberg blockade where if i have an
isolated atom i can just excite it to
the river state but if i bring it close
to another atom that's already in the
ribber state then that excitation is
forbidden
um and so the way in which we the new
point i want to make on this slide is
that the way we quantify this is with
something called a blockade radius which
is the separation between atoms
uh
uh under which you cannot excite two of
them and this is related to the
principal quantum number and your
driving strength but for kind of typical
parameters this blockade radius is you
know maybe about 10 microns whereas uh
spacing that you can engineer between
optical tweezers is something maybe
between two and five microns so this is
a really these these length scales work
out really nicely with respect to each
other because on the one hand you know
this blockade radius isn't infinity so
you can actually implement gates in
parallel across your array i can excite
an atom here to do a gate over here and
the same thing over here but at the same
time it's large enough that it
comfortably covers two you know two or
maybe even three lattice sites um so you
have some kind of flexible local
connectivity
um
and then
to to extend this uh
blockade to generating gates between
qubits we just need a selective
excitation of one of the cubit states to
the river states and i'm going to kind
of flip through this because i uh i
already introduced this um but then let
me point out that kind of the current
record fidelity is around the 98 level
and this was you know this level was
first achieved by misha lupin's group a
few years ago but has now been matched
um
by uh by i think at least two other
groups that maybe not in published data
in in exciting unpublished work that
they're rumors about
um
and then uh and then it's actually an
exciting week for this field because the
you know last week in nature i should
have updated both of these citations but
these papers were both in nature last
week both misha lukens group and and
mark safman's group um demonstrated you
know what i would call the first kind of
uh
you know
uh fully featured programmable
processors based on neutral atom qubits
um at what's really interesting to me
about these papers is that they they
have very different approaches to do
that which illustrates there's still a
lot of room for creativity and
innovation um in this neutral atom space
in the paper from misha lukens group
they implemented the programming not
actually by focusing light onto
different sites but by actually moving
the atoms with respect to each other to
change their connections so just
bringing atoms close together when they
should do a two-tiered gate moving them
far apart when they should not
um whereas in in marx saturn's approach
they they did the the the thing that was
maybe originally envisioned which is
actually focusing the station lasers
down and saying okay i'm going to excite
this queue but then this one and this
one and programming the circuit that
uh
and uh and the fact that you know
uh groups like like misha's and marx and
and also anthony's who have been sort of
pioneers in this neutral atom near
rydberg space are now doing such um such
big and impressive circuits with these
with these two bits with these neutral
atom qubits is uh
uh i think really exciting for the field
but has also kind of created the space
in which uh in which you know the work
that i'm telling you about here makes
sense where um
you know now i would say the fundamental
fact that maybe neutral atoms are
interesting is really well established
by these guys so i would describe the
work i'm telling you about here is kind
of going back to the drawing board and
thinking about what would generation two
neutral atom cubes look that work
wouldn't be possible without you know
generation one being pretty firmly
firmly established all right great quick
question jeff about yes
about um these two um results that you
just mentioned so are the gates um
applied sequentially or in parallel
um
in um in misha's case they are applied
um in parallel to some extent so there's
um
uh i but i think they're basically
applied in parallel so there's a you
know a two cubic gate happening here and
here at the same time um and then the
connectivity switches and then the gates
are done in parallel in in with this
scheme they certainly could be done in
parallel um if the addressing system
allows it i i don't actually know if
they were but mark is here
i can just say that two qubit gates were
done sequentially there are parallel one
qubit gate operations
but i think the fact that they were not
done in parallel is a question of not of
physics but of we're not a physics of
neutral atom cubits but a physics of
these modulators here um
okay um
so for our kind of you know attempt to
find second generation qubits um you
know we went back to the drawing board
and the drawing board for atomic
physicists is the periodic table
all the experiments i showed you and in
fact most of the experiments that have
been done with
atoms of any kind you know vcs you know
whatever um have been done with uh
alkali atoms from the first row of the
periodic table because they look like
hydrogen and hydrogens you know we
understand it very well
um but um but kind of the the wild west
so to speak or maybe this is like more
like chicago actually now but the the
midwest for uh four atom qubits is now
these alkaline earth atoms which have
two two electrons they look a little bit
like helium um and they have just a
slightly more complicated level
structure that gives you a lot of
additional features that you can use and
so the the work in my lab that we've
been doing is using ytterbium where
the particular reason we're drawn to a
terbium out of these is it's the only
one with a spin one half nucleus which
is really natural way to encode this key
um there's also been a lot of really
exciting work in strontium which
is maybe the better developed one of
these um and and really exciting work on
quantum simulation kind of many body
dynamics and also atomic flux it is
however very difficult to include qubits
and strong strontium because the only
nuclear spin is very large spin and so
it's difficult to isolate two-level
systems
um
we i kind of started working on this
about the same time as adam kaufman and
monolith andres atgilla and caltech
respectively um and i think this field
of using looking at alkaline earth atoms
for neutral quantum tuning is now also
taking off you know in its own right
sort of mirroring the trajectory of of
neutral items as a whole and there's you
know at least a dozen or so experiments
around the world you know also being
built now using these atomic species
um
i don't want to be too technical but let
me just give you kind of an overview of
what the features we get from this level
structure the the fact that there's two
electrons gives you singlet and triplet
states and now you have allowed
transitions conserving spin and weak
transitions flipping the spin which is
really advantageous for laser cooling
um
in the ground state there's no
electronic spin so nuclear spin the
qubit if you have a nuclear spin should
have essentially infinite coherence um
there's also this highly forbidden
optical transition which is the basis of
optical atomic flux which i think will
someday redefine the si second but for
our purpose just gives you another way
to encode a qubit and in fact you can
use this nuclear spin in this in this
metastable qubit as well
um in this metastable electronic state
as well it also has no electronic
angular momentum
um and then the other feature is that
within this ceterbium ion atom we have a
ytterbium ion inside the core and
manipulating the optical transitions of
that ion within the rydberg atom has
actually has turned out to be maybe the
most useful feature that's particularly
important for these error correction
items
so i don't claim to have explained all
of these things in enough detail to
understand them especially uh especially
maybe for this more theoretically
inclined audience but but maybe the
metaphor that i want to have here is
that these uh you know this is our
toolkit and these alkaline earth atoms
are really like the swiss army knife
where they have all kinds of weird and
potentially dangerous appendages on them
and uh and what we've been doing for the
last few years is basically trying to
figure out if we can do anything useful
with anything this error correction work
is is one thing in that category
um so over the last few years in my
group we've kind of learned how to cool
and trap uh attribution atoms and
optical tweezers measured done a lot of
i would say foundational work like
measuring where their ribbon states are
and verifying that they have strong
interactions both which were not really
known before our work and then very
recent in very recent work we've
actually implemented finally a full set
of qubit operations um in these atoms
and actually uh our our paper
demonstrating a universal set of data
operations in the 171 terbium just came
out in prx a couple hours ago uh
accompanied by a paper from adam
california's group with doing very
similar work in the same species
um
so uh just to kind of flash up you know
the fact that these two bits work we uh
we you know we we do sort of have a
pretty typical set of tricks for
initializing the qubit into one of these
spin states for example using optical
pumping um and then we use in our case a
global rf field to drive robbie
oscillations to do single cubic gate
rotations between these and uh and get
nice oscillations um in our work this is
done globally uh we have only global
addressing for single qubit gates at the
moment um using rf but but adam
kaufman's groups demonstrated optical
raman gates also with global addressing
but the path to uh to implementing them
on a single site is clear using their
approach
um any single cubic gates work well you
know the the single qubit randomized
benchmarking fidelity is high which it
should be for you know for just doing
robby oscillations on a spin
um we implement two cubic gates using
the approach that i described where we
excite them to the rydberg state the
thing that's a little bit funny for the
for the experts in the audience about
how we
do uh these ribber gates is that um the
the selective coupling of just one of
the qubit levels to the rydberg state is
achieved actually not using selection
rules or energy splitting in the ground
states which are almost degenerate but
actually using azam on splitting in the
so so the reason only one goes to the
right birch state is because of the
splitting up here
um and we use uh this this gate protocol
um that from from misha lukens group
that i described earlier um to implement
our two cubic gates and uh and we get um
reasonably okay performance for the very
first demonstration of a two cubic k in
an alkaline fat it's about eighty
percent eighty three percent uh two
cubic fidelity after we do spam
correction we have
we understand this to be limited
primarily by technical noise and laser
noise we
our laser system was not especially
optimized to do this particular gate but
it's sort of an existence proof that you
release can do gates in this atom
so what we're working on now is
um uh
promoting instead of encoding cube it's
in this ground state encoding cubits in
this meta stable state part of the
motivation for doing that is this error
correction work i described but the
other reason which that we were already
working on this is actually that this is
just a better state to do gates from in
the first place because we can get much
faster extinction to the rydberg states
starting from this state using only a
single photon transition instead of
having to use a two photon transition
from the ground state so this is already
a really good idea
from just from the perspective of this
atomic physics
um and uh this so and we actually think
we should be able to do our gates you
know maybe somewhere between 10 and 20
times faster starting from this state
which should actually give us a 10 to 20
squared times improvement in technical
noise um which is what we're counting on
to get these fifty states better
using the metastable state also actually
lets you do mid circuit measurement very
well in a way that i will talk about
today
um
so um so having introduced kind of a
little bit about these neutral atom
cubes and in particular terbium then let
me tell you how we
uh in the context of the specific energy
levels here can implement this error
model uh or a qubit encoding that gives
rise to this error model where we have
primarily uh detectable ratio errors
um so our qubit
i guess in in an abstract sentence as i
drew earlier you have two ground states
that store your qubit and then the
rydberg state decays and gives rise to
errors
but now we use a meta-stable state not
the ground state to encode this qubit
and it's the triplet p zero state which
in eterbium has a lifetime of 20 seconds
so it's a very long run state even
though it's not infinite
um so now let's kind of account for
where the errors from this state go so
it turns out and
this these numbers come from just you
know atomic physics the matrix elements
that we pretty much know for ytterbium
um 34 of the errors are actually going
to come back down to the real atomic
ground state
and when they do we can detect them by
using fluorescence on this you know
singlet zero this thing with p1
transition which is a closed cycling
transition has negligible probability of
decaying into these two bit states um
and also this light is not resonant with
any transitions starting from this state
so so applying this light is both not
going to put these two bits back into
the computational space but is also not
going to kick any more qubits out of the
computational space
so being able to efficiently detect
these converts these decays into erasure
errors
another big chunk almost two-thirds of
the the sort of decays from this
rhythmic state aren't
aren't actually really spontaneous
decays at all but their black body
photon induced transitions to other
rydberg states up to these very high
principle quantum numbers you have kind
of microwave frequency transitions
between states and those can be driven
by thermal radiation um and these we can
detect by converting them after a gate
we can apply a pulse of light that's
resonated with the yoterbium plus
transition inside the core of this atom
and that through a process called
autoionization within like 100
picoseconds creates a terbium plus ion
and that terbium plus ion
we can also detect with fluorescence on
its cycling transition which also is not
going to disturb qubits in this state
because this light is also very far
determined from transmissions from here
these ions are not trapped so it's a
little bit harder to detect them but we
think with very realistic parameters
this can be done with at least 99
percent and then these also become
erasures i'll also point out that this
auto ionization process doesn't actually
care about which rydberg state you are
in it detects both these other rydberg
states that can be populated by black
body transitions but also this original
red burn state here so you also catch
any leakage
from the gate into this state
with this approach
so then in the end only five percent of
the errors decay back to this
computational space um where they could
cause cuba errors so basically with this
encoding and given the way these energy
levels or these matrix elements work out
in a terbium we've engineered a qubit
that has a really high fraction of
errors it's these erasures
um
the reason this works well maybe
uh or sorry so to understand kind of
quantitatively how this uh you know
where these numbers come from i've first
plotted here just the branching ratios
of where it decays from a particular
river state i think it's a 75s 3s1 and
what you see is that you know about most
of the errors about two-thirds of the
errors are blackbody one-third are
radiative but among these radiative
errors um various selection rules tend
to favor higher j states and and and
what not such that actually the fraction
of uh
these decays that go back to the qubit
subspaces 3p0 is just very small and
this is just a combination of all these
selection rules and angular momentum
tendencies
but actually there's another so it's
only five if once you include the
multi-photon decays for these states
it's five percent they come back to 3v0
but it actually turns out that if those
decays happen in the middle of the gate
they have a relatively high probability
70 of being re-excited to the rydberg
state by you know the rest of the gate
because our laser is still on um and and
those re-exciting qubits also are
converted into ions at the end of the
detected isolations so when you kind of
multiply this five percent seventy
percent together then it actually in the
end is only only two percent of errors
that are
end up back in the cupid's face or
another way is that 98 percent of the
errors become decays become erasures
um sorry can i ask you a naive question
here um yes please so so is is is there
one relevant number or two you know one
relevant number seems to be
what what percentage go back to the
qubit space
and then
is there a different number which is
what percentage do you actually detect
and
and is there a middle number and what
how do you think of that one
yeah so i
um
well there's what percentage go well
okay i would say there's there's what
percentage go back to the qubit space
and what percentage don't and those add
up to once um and uh but then uh the
ones that go don't go back to your qubit
space are you know they're definitely
kind of lost from your computation so
then
if you can detect them it's very
beneficial that they're these erasures
but it's not necessarily the case that
you detect all of them right so there's
a question what is the detection
fidelity for those atoms that leave the
qubit space um you know when there's an
error and uh and we think that i mean
detecting atoms with like atoms single
atoms are actually quite bright in terms
of fluorescence so for these ground
state atoms we're quite confident that
we can do this at the three ninth level
for these ions i think two you know two
nines is a more realistic estimate um so
there is a question which we have not
actually analyzed in detail of what is
the impact of missing a small fraction
of these events
um that is a separate number
and sorry just following up on that a
little bit so
so the the ones that
were
lost you know where um
did not go back to the uh to the the
computational space but um
and you did not detect them so now there
would be a missing qubit there so how
does that affect the subsequent
computation
yeah so i mean and atoms can get lost
for other reasons too you know they can
get knocked out of the trap by
background gas or they can just fall out
of the trap for other reasons so it's
not an error that's of a kind that's
fundamentally distinct from errors that
you would have to deal with to be you
know rigorously fault-tolerant anyways
um so there are uh but but this is more
like kind of a classic leakage error so
i think there's a lot of
a lot of proposals i mean mark has a
review paper from from 2016 where he
proposes this sort of knock knock uh
protocol from from preschool uh to deal
with this i think there are actually
probably more clever um
uh
schemes to deal with this more
efficiently like in the surface code and
i think at the end of our paper we cite
a paper from uh sutara cross and
gambetta from ibm on this sort of quick
leak introduction circuit that actually
seems like it should work with pretty
minimal impact on the overhead where you
basically swap the data in the ancillary
qubits after every cycle to try to
detect since you detect the until every
time you can tell if it's missing um but
we have not analyzed that quantitatively
but i think it's not going to be a big
deal if it's rare
there's there's also a question in the
chat from uh do you want to ask that
uh
directly there
yeah
yeah so the question is uh will there be
back caching error even if there's no
leakage events
what do you mean
it's like if you don't protect the
leakage it's more likely it will be in
the zero state
so that's on my that i think that comes
up in one slide okay so yeah
um
so on this slide exactly so um
so and then so you know this this 98
comes from some kind of analytic
calculation but to sort of
validate this understanding we also did
master equation simulations of the full
two cubic gate and uh and what we see is
that the sort of the total you know the
average gate fidelity gets better as you
do your gates faster and faster but then
if you condition on not detecting one of
these leakage events then it's better by
a factor of 50 still and this 50 is this
98 percent cast in the inverse it's one
over one over two percent um
so uh so you get a big conditional
improvement in the fidelity but by by
not having an erasure error but there's
still some small probability of an error
um but this actually consists of two
parts one you know one is the error from
decays you know back down into qubit
subspace which which can cause uh you
know reveals information to the
environment about what the state of the
cubit is now but also the fact that you
didn't have an error gives you this kind
of no jump evolution which is what i
think you were asking about the end um
that even if you if you keep running
gates over and over and you never see
any erasure errors that eventually tells
you that your qubits have to be in the
zero state because if the one state is
the only one that goes to the river
today there should have been an error
eventually um in terms of this average
gate fidelity you know this is quadratic
with the error probability so in the
regime you want to be in it's
conditionally very small
um but it's an interesting question of
how whether this because it's a coherent
error whether it actually really
you know whether this average gate
fidelity that's quadratic is actually
the right measure for um
for for uh thinking that these are
correcting codes and that's something
i'd be happy to discuss later
the other thing that's important though
in this simulation is there's actually
different
kinds of signals you can get for
detecting errors the atoms can you know
one can go down to the ground state one
can become an ion they can both go down
to the ground state um and we can detect
most of those but if both atoms in a two
cubic gate become ions at the end of the
gate then that we actually can't detect
because if you create those two ions
within a few microns of each other they
just blow each other you know the
repulsive force between them is so
strong that they'll leave before we can
detect them
but one thing that was kind of a nice
surprise i can't really say that we
designed it um is that that the
probability of creating the kind of air
that gives you two ions is very strongly
suppressed by the red bird blockade it's
actually an even stronger blockade than
the normal blockade that suppresses
those type of events from happening so
their the probability of those things
happening is suppressed by you know many
four or five orders of magnitude
compared to uh compared to the errors
that were mainly worried about defecting
um so that was a
pleasant surprise
um
so the i have only one more point i want
to make which is that you know all of
this discussion so far has been about
only two qubit errors and only two cubic
errors arising from the finite lifetime
of the reverb state and i don't think
this is like completely irrelevant
because that is the only fundamental
limitation of the fidelity foods but but
there are other errors that you know by
uh for for sort of technical reasons
which can be
as insurmountable as physics in some
cases uh there's other errors that
happen and what about those you know
what's our budget for those or do we
have to worry about those eroding our
adventure and so the one of these the
one type of error that we studied in our
paper is initialization and measurement
errors and we have a pretty good handle
in our system and other neutral atom
systems this can be done at this sort of
99 level and just by inserting those
into our circuit level simulations what
we found is that they have actually
pretty minimal impact um the you know
the solid lines show the kind of the
logical error rate for zero percent for
no initialization measurement errors and
the dashed lines are half a percent um
which is reflective of some
state-of-the-art value and these don't
matter very much and that's consistent
with other simulations of the surface
code that you know these those kinds of
errors are way less important than two
cubic gate errors
um but there's other types of errors
that we haven't considered in detail but
i want to just kind of lay out our
thinking about them um maybe spark some
conversations
the first is that you know the new era
that we've introduced by going to this
meta-stable state is that we have to
worry about the finite lifetime of that
state you know it can decay we in the
ground state we would have had a a an
almost infinitely limped qubit now we
have this finite uh lifetime this one i
really don't think matters very much
because you know what happens when it
decays it goes to the ground state and
that's an erration error so i think to
the extent that these arrays and it's
just a single configuration here and
we'll detect it with our normal
protocols so this one is i think is not
going to matter at all
um there's also an issue of doing you
know locally addressed single qubit
gates using raman transitions the level
diagram looks similar to these redbird
states but you're not going to very
highly excited states and here i think
it's likely that you'll have essentially
a same a similar fraction of conversion
into erasure errors because the
selection rules coming from these
intermediate excited states are similar
to the ripple states
the but the one that's more important is
coherent errors so you know lasers are
noisy atoms move around and that gives
rise to doppler shifts um and this can
cause problems for both single and two
cubic gates and these are actually in in
current implementations you know
among the the dominant errors and i
think the same thing actually applies
for ion traps
um and here the the vision that we have
for how to handle these which were is
sort of an open you know research
question for us right now um
theoretically and experimentally is to
use a technique known as um
uh you know composite pulse sequences to
drive these gates and the idea is that
instead of say doing a single two pi
pulse to the rhythmic state in back you
actually do a series of maybe pi pulses
or pi over three pulses or maybe some
optimal control sequence optimal control
drive sequence which executes some more
complicated and longer trajectory you
spend more time in this river state on
average but does it in a way that the
fidelity of the final gate is robust
to like a higher order
against
uh errors in the parameters like for
example the robbie frequency of the
laser or the detuning of the laser
and so what these composite pulse
sequences let you do is trade robustness
against rotation errors for a longer
sequence basically trade
you know coherent errors for spontaneous
errors which would arise from the longer
sequence um so actually in the you know
my understanding is that in trapped ion
qubits there's a lot of there's been a
lot of work on these kinds of gates but
they have not actually realized a
significant benefit in practice because
um the fact that you make these things
longer increases the the gate error rate
from uh
uh
from motional heating and things like
that so it ends up being a wash
basically whether you do this or not but
in in our case because we have this
conversion of spontaneous decay errors
from the river state into erasure errors
we would actually much prefer to trade
rotation errors for that um so i think
this might create a new a new
perspective and a new argument for the
use of these kinds of pulses but we're
actually trying to understand how well
these work for rydberg states um
but maybe the final thought here is that
you know all you actually have to if you
want to have this very advantageous
noise model you have to consider not
only the error you want to but actually
all the operations and think carefully
about them to maintain the significant
bias towards erasure
um so i uh
i guess uh
maybe have two very thin concluding
remarks here the first is that you know
the fact that this works in this atomic
species 171 and terbium actually kind of
involves a number of what appear to be
miracles about you know how these atomic
properties work out um which is really
unique and nice um and the second is
that this project that we embarked on
with true tea of really trying to code
and shimon and ua of really trying to
co-design uh you know a physical cubit
encoding and an error correction code
was uh is actually very difficult at
first to really learn to speak each
other's language but i think was very
productive in the end and very exciting
and i think that this kind of work is uh
is you know this system level thinking
is is something that that
i hope can be reproduced you know across
the field
um
uh so with that i'd like to then i thank
the theory collaborators at the
beginning i'd like to thank my students
who actually did this experimental work
here at the end of our talk here's a
picture of a neutral atom quantum
computer and then also thank you for
your attention
all right
great thank you
jeff that was a beautiful talk
it's so real for for speaking of the
theoretician it was a real window into
into
you know the experimental way of
thinking about things there as well as
really beautiful ideas so let's see if
there are any
any other quick questions before we move
on to the panel
hi manuel
hey jeff
beautiful talk really great results i'm
wondering and there's nothing
that prevents me from from doing this in
analog quantum simulation as well right
i mean i could
say if i have just an encoding from a
metastable to a rootback state detect
these kinds of errors the same way
and try to enhance my fidelity by just
post selection
yes i i think post selection would be
would definitely work for you
i think the challenge the thing that's a
little more favorable about circuit
model um computing is that you know we
bring all of our population back down
from the river state periodically during
the computation and that gives us a
chance to create and clear out these
ions um i think at least in the
experiment in these kind of quench
experiments where you're doing now you
want to have a large circuit depth but
that's kind of continuous evolution you
know including the ribber states and if
you make any ions or anything like that
in the middle you're totally screwed um
but but post selection at least you
could figure out after the fact if it
happened so like a heralded um
heralded uh thing you could definitely
do
yeah i wonder about similar equations
for coherent errors because i mean
some of the laser errors you can
classically detect i believe right say
if you have amplitude noise
specifically for rigberg say intensity
noise is extremely hard to stabilize
because it's so fast but say you have
extremely good phototite you know what
you know what it is right so you could
post select like that and detect it
uh maybe you could also select it with
like
a bunch of kind of ancillary atoms that
would see it or something like this i
think that might be something like that
it might not be a hundred percent maybe
you get another ten or twenty percent
like that
i think those are really interesting
ideas yeah
umesh i think you're muted sorry steve
you have a question
hi yeah uh thanks for the wonderful talk
so um you did your work with the xczx
code
um
do you
know if there's any real reason
why that's a good code to use in the
context of erasure or if other codes
might perform similarly
um i have asked that question to shruti
as well and i think
the the the answer is no there's no
reason to believe that it would work
better i think they were already working
with it in the context of their bias
noise stuff and had all the
infrastructure set up but
thanks
um are there is any other question
before we move on to the panel
okay so uh so jeff if you could stop
sharing your slides then
then we could maybe
get the panelist
video spinned
okay there in the meantime there's a
there's a
question in the chat is any benefit of
continuous illumination where errors
would appear stochastically
but immediately
um i see so if i if i illumi instead of
pulsing on the illumination to detect
these errors at the end of a gate i keep
it on continuously to try to detect you
know exactly the moment the gate that it
occurs
um
it's
hard for me to think about what the
benefit of that would be because i think
at the end of the day
you know the qubit is depolarized
basically i mean you could maybe argue
that if if you cut if you saw that the
error happened you know in the first ten
percent of a two cubic gate then you
sort of know that the error probability
is very small
but i don't that's a very small amount
of additional information and i don't i
don't know
it's an interesting idea though
okay um great can we can we get the
panelists videos
okay perfect
so um
let me start introducing the panelists
we have a really uh fantastic panel
today um
uh we have
ken brown from uh
from duke university he's
he's actually a professor in ec physics
and chemistry uh
and he works
on quantum computer architecture on
quantum control and and of course
quantum error correcting code so very
appropriate for for this particular
topic um there's um
ignacio sirach who is at the max planck
institute ignacio is a theorist who
works broadly on you know everything
you've probably heard of you know seen
here on panels before but for our for
our particular talk today uh you know i
think what's what's interesting is that
many of the
original proposals
experimental proposals for
experimental quantum computing came from
ignacio and his work with peter zoller
so
great to have you here uh we have
lianzan uh who is who is on the faculty
at uh at chicago
he's a theorist um and he works on
sensing
communication quantum quantum
computation but with again as a special
uh
emphasis on quantum era correction which
is uh
so welcome
and then
mark certman uh from wisconsin uh who's
an experimental atomic physicist and
and jeff already spoke about how
important his experiments are to setting
up the the foundations of what
jeff has been talking about
so uh
you know it would be it would be good to
start with um with the reactions of the
panelists to to what was uh to jeff's
talk um maybe uh in some order maybe
ignacio do you want to
do you want to start
yes of course
well first of all thank you very much
for this beautiful talk it was i think
very clear for
everybody physicists computer scientists
at this part of the of the
of the talk and i think it's a very nice
idea very good idea and i think that it
is needed at the moment so it's uh
methods to
trying to scale up our systems and
reduce the errors and in that sense i
mean the way i understood it i think
it's a good idea that has a practical
application
i mean i have some some
questions maybe i'm not so urgent i
don't know if i should uh ask them now
or later on
sure why not yes please please do
yeah so my question is about time scales
so somehow maybe i'm i'm i'm i'm
not up to date but for my for my i
thought the redbird
gates are very interesting because they
can be very fast as compared to some
other gates like collisions they have
other other
but that's one of them
and
however i guess that when you start to
measure
and do the measurements and wait until
you have the result in order to act
and in particular indicate that you
would lose the uh the atoms and they go
away you have to replace them then this
will take some time and so i'm wondering
to what extent this diminishes some of
the advantages that the rivers have or
if on i mean it's something that is
independent
um should i should we should i answer
that yeah so yeah that's a good question
and in fact uh when when we showed a
draft of this paper to mark zap and that
was also his first question and uh and
as a result
i think it's like supplementary section
s27 or whatever has a little bit of a
sketch of this um but i think the
essence of it is though that um
you know the ribber gates are very fast
maybe a few hundred nanoseconds um you
uh but this erasure detection because
you're not trying to
keep the atoms we we do this detection
in a in sword we just blast the atoms in
the resonant light um that actually can
also be very fast just at the level of a
few microseconds um is how long that
would take um because these are strong
transitions that's very different from
um the current state of the art from say
doing a measurement of an ancillary
qubit where you want to measure what its
spin state is but you also want to keep
the atom so you can reuse that and
similar to it in current implementations
that's
depending on the system somewhere
between like 20 and 100 milliseconds um
so that's actually very slow orders of
magnitude
so what we work out in in the supplement
to our paper is that if when you get to
measure the ancillas um uh which you do
less frequently when we stabilize your
measurements you have to do this slow
readout with current technology then all
this erasure stuff isn't going to change
the cycle time at all um and
that in order for
for it to become the limit to the cycle
time you would have to speed up that
ancillary measurement by about two
orders of magnitude um so people this is
a known problem and people are working
on it um the other operation in here
that's not that fast is replacing the
atoms but i think that's not going to
turn out to be a big limitation because
you don't have to do it right away you
know in the circuit that i drew we did
it right away but there's certainly no
point in doing it until at least you
finish the next round of stabilizer
measurements so you can actually batch a
number of these atom replacements and do
them at the same time and the work of
misha and others has shown that parallel
atom moves are you know essentially free
compared to single atom moves um because
it's just the acceleration time of some
whole pattern um so i'm also pretty
optimistic that that's not going to
affect the operation time
okay thanks
thanks ignacio so who would like to go
next um
i can go next oh great mark
so jeff thanks for the great talk i
think this is the second time i've heard
you give this talk and it was even
better on the second time so i
enjoyed hearing you go through it again
um you know actually i want to say i
think one of the aspects that you didn't
emphasize
although in fact is implicit in this
architecture which is very valuable is
that you can
recall individual atoms could be the
atoms you've replaced or any other atom
without affecting other atoms in the
circuit in a way that is really very
difficult
in other elements because you can take
your triplet p0 out adam put it down to
the ground state and cool it nicely
without affecting any other qubits and
that's actually a very important feature
um
thinking about cooling i would also
mention that
you know i agree with your rough
estimates about the impact on cycle time
from the the atom replacement there
probably has to be some amount of
recooling uh included in that and that
may add to your your time budget but you
know these are these are details that
will be developed and need to be worked
out over time
um
yeah i mean i would just say overall i
find it a very
interesting proposal i'm still trying to
find the missing the hole in it that
hasn't been discovered yet but it does
look very promising for for further
study let me stop there for now okay
thanks mark
so so can i add a comment i think this
is a really nice work and also it kind
of like comes timely
as a kind of a co-design in terms of the
hardware and also efficient error
correction
and
i think what's kind of impressive is
it's just not like you identify the
error but also you kind of engineer and
try to convert the error into a really
like more favorable erasure error so
that you can actually significantly
boost the performance in terms of using
more favorable error correction
yeah so yeah really nice readout
great thank you thank you dan
uh ken it's olios yeah um well liang
took one of my main talking points uh
but
i think the conversion to ratios is
amazing and i think other platforms
should take the time to think about how
to do it
because i don't think
um
yeah i think the community is a little
bit missed the fact how much better our
ratios are for error correction if we
can
you know re-initialize and
uh
replace
second thing i'm super excited about is
the part with composite pulses
so um
is a quick
i don't know minor correction which is
like the one cubic composite pulses we
use all the time
the two cubic positive pulses and ion
traps yeah we do suffer from this
heating rate
and i think
um
if you could demonstrate the kind of um
two cubic composite pulse which is like
uh one cube cubic puzzle pulse
related to kind of
using type interaction
suggested by jones jonathan jones a long
time ago
um it could be the first system where it
actually helps
and i think that in itself would be
pretty cool
um so
should i think that the um the amount of
erasure just goes like time and do you
have a sense of like what the tradeoff
should be between kind of over rotation
angle versus extra erasure
um
yes well first of all thank you for
making that point about two cubic gators
i i was
thinking about two cubic gate errors um
but but yes that's true um uh
um
the trade-off so i would think about it
this way so
if um
if i had if i was not thinking about
erasure conversion and i was just or
types of errors and i was just generally
concerned about the error rate okay i
could have the situation where i had
let's say 50
of my error came from an over or another
rotation and fifty percent came from
spontaneous
and in that case if what my composite
pulse let me do was you know suppress
my um let's say my error probability is
small so my composite pulse is going to
suppress that coherent part basically to
zero but at the expense of doubling the
length of my gate so i now double the
spontaneous part
in many contexts that's a the error
probability is the same the total error
probability is the same so you don't map
but for us um
that the you know the first case would
basically be described as
uh let's say only 50 erasure conversion
because this spontaneous part is only
half my total error and then the other
half is just a cubit error um and so i
could go from the case of having an
error probability you know 2p and 50
ratio conversion to 2p and 100 or you
know 98 ratio conversion that's way more
favorable so i don't know exactly how to
quantify that trade except to say that i
think you would almost always take it
here
there's one other thing about it which
is that actually
when you talk about composite pulses for
like trapped ions you're actually kind
of trying to suppress two errors at the
same time one is leakage and the other
is that given that there's no leakage
you have the right reality gate and we
have a slightly more relaxed condition
here which is that we don't we can
ignore leakage we can only optimize over
the fidelity when you come back because
any leakage just becomes erasure so we
might even be able to have more
efficient composite pulse gates than
what are possible
in other systems because of that
yeah sounds like a great shadow
great um
let me uh let me just ask something more
general here so
again going back to
you know a very uh naive view of um
or maybe
you know
uh you know either lay person or a
terrorist view of you know where errors
come from and you know there's this very
general argument that's made that
it's you know if you had isolated qubits
you can you can make them almost perfect
but as soon as you start interacting
with them which is what you need to do
for gates you you must have
you know that's where errors start
creeping in and you must have the
occurrence rates so
um is
let me let me just try to see you know
ask you jeff as well as a panel you know
in general um so
in view of this talk you know
is it is that um i'm i'm trying to
see how to update my thinking about this
so here here's one thought that i have
which is
okay so single qubit gates are always
you know
uh much more reliable than two cubic
gates and you know and this argument
that well if you want to if you want to
implement gates you have to you have to
control from the outside and therefore
they'll inevitably be errors it seems to
apply equally to single qubit and two
qubit gates so are you
you know is is one way to think about
what you're saying uh you know is uh if
you were to extrapolate it is is it an
arguments thing look there's no reason
why two qubit gates shouldn't be as good
as single qubit gates and
you know maybe this this argument that
one one usually thinks of
in the abstract
it
it really applies to just controlling
stuff but maybe when when you're when
you're when you have two qubits
interacting with each other well in in
your case it's you know it's through the
rydberg blockade and
maybe that doesn't introduce errors it's
just a matter stable state and you can
by converting it into erasures you can
you can sort of get rid of those errors
or or make them much more tractable so
is this a you know could then formulate
this as a more general principle and is
the is there is there hope that we can
pursue it in
many other
uh you know
other settings
you know if you have comments or any
video from this panel i'm just trying to
understand how i should think about this
more generally
so maybe i can say something
here
so first i mean it's a question just
look at the history you know i mean
single qubit gates have been done
already for 60 years 80 years or even
longer whether it gets too much longer
so there must be a reason for that and
so no one can analyze what is the reason
and i guess that there are different
aspects one aspect could be
that if you want to do a single qubit
gage you use what we would call a
classical field to interact with it so
this is this laser field microwave field
which is full of photons right so it's
not acting a single system with a single
quantum system is one
single system with a huge quantum system
that has very little fluctuations
basically classical whereas when we want
to do
uh two qubit case they will have to act
one system which is quantum with another
system that is quantum and then it's
much weaker the interaction and
i don't know that could be one one way
of looking at it but i'm sure that there
are other ways to being attacked
and so sir sorry that's still following
up on that um so now when when you when
you have something like this with
blockade you know i is
is the
um
you know should i think of the moral of
this story as saying well that's
you know that's pretty reliable in
itself the
you know the
the the noise really comes from other
sources and maybe that's not inherent or
you know what what's the take away
i mean is there is there another step
beyond that that
well i don't know i guess there are many
ways of seeing it but if you see you
have a single atom and you put the huge
electric field and you make it rotate i
mean something will happen you will get
two gates with that
and now the idea that you have to do it
with another atom and you have to create
a huge electric field what you do is
that you put it in the register
requested it's very close and then it's
a huge electric field as if it was an
external one and this mimics a little
disorder situation and that's why it's
very fast and kind of robust
maybe i can add a comment actually i
think jeff mentioned this right at the
beginning of his talk that the way that
two cubic gates are done with neutral
atoms or trapped iron qubits
involves taking the physical system out
of the qubit space out of the
computational space and coupling it to
some other degrees of freedom that are
not entirely stable so either to the
motional state where we have more
susceptibility to noise in the case of
ions or to these ribber states that have
a finite lifetime with respect to
spontaneous decay it's that finite
lifetime that leads to to errors in
these systems and so i mean i i think
it's because of this it's intrinsically
more difficult and certainly the history
bears this out that it's harder to
perform two cubic gates with uh low
errors than it is one cubic gates but i
would not characterize that difficulty
is fundamental i mean i think there's
uh an opportunity and a path forwards
where the two qubit fidelities can be as
high or higher than the one qubit
fidelities that we see today but there's
more work that needs to be done there's
more engineering i mean there's also
other ideas for example
uh utilizing these very long live
redburg states the circular states that
the roach group has pioneered and jeff
also has a nice paper on there's other
papers also
which uh
allow you to take advantage of the
strong interactions of the footberg
states while reducing the decay rates by
orders of magnitude so there's a path
there to at least on paper get to ten to
the minus five ten to the minus six two
cubic eight hours so it's going to be
hard but you know certainly there's a
there's a direction one can explore
i want to connect to different part of
amish's question which in terms of like
the theory world versus the real world
i think one really nice thing about
jeff's work is that the
um and then actually
doing similar work on other error models
is that error has structure
and so
normally in these most quantum era
correction papers for a long time people
were like oh we don't know anything
about the errors we just randomly select
them from the polygroup on support over
the weight of the operation
and that's a great thing to do if you
don't know anything
but actually any real
two cubic single cubic gate the areas
have a lot of structure
and i think it's been really nice in the
last um i'd say the last five years
seeing um control theorists and
experimentalists work with error
correction theorists to actually make
better codes
based on that structure and i actually
think there'll be a lot more work along
that direction in the next couple years
so
follow following up on that ken so
are there
you know
are there already very general
principles emerging or is this still in
process
where would you characterize that
network
how would you give the big picture
i would say um i would say it's still in
process um i mean i think erasure errors
is a good
like new thing like oh yeah we had all
the rationales was good
um to me the one question that that
jeff's paper answered for me
was like what fraction of a ratio errors
do i need to have some gain
and it turns out that gives you kind of
a sense of when it pays off or not
um in this work
unrelated work with like uh
cat codes with errors that gate
transparent errors that's really neat
because you can think about basically
making almost classical codes where the
nodes are so biased one way or the other
um but i think what's missing
is uh
yeah anyway this is just my goofy
example which is
what if your error model was you just
drop gates
like occasionally you just don't apply
the gate
i can make a normal error correction
code that fixes poly errors that fixes
that error
but i don't actually have the tools to
make a code
that
yeah i don't have the tools to make a
code based on that idea
and i think if we if we could start to
make tools that were
not us making poly errors and then
finding the right match to the physical
errors but actually based on the
physical errors so be quite nice
nice
yeah so so can i also maybe another
related comment is that i think that's
in jeff's system what's interesting is
that there exists a very clean
q and d measurement to detect the
erasure error without causing a
significant any damage to the remaining
system which of course still needs to be
experimentally demonstrated but it seems
really promising that basically you have
all the other different colors of laser
to detect those states without
compromising the other system which at
least in some of the earlier work in
supernatural circuits usually when you
measure something you'll have t1 induced
decay and so on so the system starts to
collapse like decay faster but the if if
what kind of like uh this in this system
you can kind of detect those erasure
error without causing much damage it's
actually a very efficient way to extract
entropy from the system which is really
nice to actually for the control and the
error correction yeah
great
yeah ask one one other question which um
i guess going back to these um
what you mentioned with the bias
preserving gates and so on
so is it the case that that with erasure
errors that um
okay so
let me let me first say my understanding
my understanding was that you need the
bias preserving gates to make sure that
when you're when you're doing
you know this recursive error correction
or something like that you know when you
when you concatenate and so on that that
you end up getting
getting those those biased errors again
right at the next level so if you were
doing the same thing with with erasures
do you need now erasure preserving gates
or
how how would you see this but
if we talk through this
i i mean my my what i i'm about to say
might be very naive but but the way the
way i think about biased preserving
gates is is really that um
you know it's natural that like a zzz
gate that zeros commute with a gate so
if you have a zero during the gate it's
gonna be zero at the end but that's not
true for control x for example so um so
you but you can make it control the x
out of z gates now you have hadamards
that flip you know x to the zeros and so
the thing about erasure errors is it's
just you just highlight a qubit um and
say this cube it has an error and then
you can track that through gates you
know
it doesn't um it doesn't you know it's
not like that error magically pops up on
another qubit you can track the spread
even if you wait a while before you
detect you contract an error here it
turns into errors on these qubits so it
just kind of goes through gates in a
pretty natural way if you had an error
before a gate you still have an error
you see
okay
great
um
well can i add a comment to that i think
that
in principle there's still some related
discussion about how to default
tolerance even in the presence of
erasure errors right because in
principle when you have ancillar measure
some like a syndromes associated with
the irish error you might still
propagate those erasure to some other
like a couple of qubits and there's also
some like work related if you can use
flat qubits or other better designs to
make sure that they still do the error
correction for tolerantly and and i
guess that probably here is maybe you
have a mixture of erasure and the
depolarization error maybe depending on
the fraction of these different types of
error maybe you may want to optimize the
different codes and circuit designs to
get a better performance in terms of
hardware efficiency and
thresholds yeah which i think is
probably related to steve flemier's
question that uh to
are there better codes compared to the
xdzx code which may be better benefited
for this kind of uh different ratios of
erasure and the depolarization error and
i think that that actually would be
something interesting also to look into
for series especially yeah
i'm so glad you brought up flag qubits
because uh
i you know i wanted to ask
if
if you or somebody else wants to wants
to talk about
it seems like there you are trying to
uh with flag qubits also move towards
eurasia's right so
is it it would be interesting to sort of
speak about these two and uh you know
can can can you say something more
general about that um yeah so recently
we had a paper on the correcting again
another type of erasure error which is
about like a synchronizing circuit this
cosmic ray events
which you can think of as an entire
coding block has erasure but the way to
solve this is to have a next level of
coding
and connecting different chips and once
you detect erasure you can use a second
level of coding to correct that erasure
and then there was some discussion at
least in a paper we also think about
using flat qubits to suppress them
and but but okay it's just at the
beginning because we only consider the
irish error but in practice there could
be combination of erasure and the other
gate errors maybe they're more efficient
or general design
to correct those but that's only okay a
little bit part that they're thinking so
far but maybe they are more general
maybe ken can add more comments on this
one too
yeah well i think um
okay so so okay so first glance why is
erasure erasure seems terrible like
you've totally lost your qubit
um but what separates it from say like a
leakage type error where you've also
totally lost your qubit is that you know
where it occurred
right and so flag qubits
in some sense that's what they do is
they they let you know
which set of c knots
had a two cubic gear
right
and so it it it
uh unfortunately in the black cubit
scheme you can't actually check
everything it doesn't work out
uh but it it's somewhere between like a
race i think i think that's a nice way
to think about it it's kind of between
erasure and the other way because we
have we at least have scoped it down to
a narrow region of errors
yeah or maybe a related comment is that
uh maybe during error correction one
could do it adaptively depending on what
you see you will decide
what to do next
then the kind of the flag qubit schemes
will have this kind of in the design and
so that will probably give a more
efficient like a strategy in correcting
errors
that's actually that's very interesting
i hadn't thought about flag qubits as
being you know in between erasures and
other things but but i think i see i
kind of
thought about other maybe like like less
efficient schemes for detecting erasures
where or for detecting atoms with a week
where maybe you have to use some
additional
additional qubits and then what i
wondered about those is how you would
characterize um
how you would characterize you know this
spectrum from depolarizing errors to
erasure
do you know because with erasures you
have this double this like higher
distance right then the steeper slope so
do you know where like flag qubits fall
on that spectrum that you get a larger
effective code distance or
or not
there it's i think a little bit
orthogonal
because the erasure helps you even if
you have like a code capacity model of
errors from just sending information to
your channel
and flag qubits just makes sense when
you
when you're like building the gadgets to
look for parody checks
so it's a little bit
yeah it's not quite
apples to apples there
but but but i do think um
the thing which is important is that the
decoder side of an error correcting code
the more information it has the better
it can do and so ratio is an example
where it has a lot of information
flags give us more information than not
using flags
and then
i would say that's the kind of the
things in between so like if i have um
yeah if i have some extra promises on my
errors for some reason
i can actually in my decoder use that to
make the threshold better
yeah maybe to jeff's question i think
it's maybe more related to like a code
design like rather than just using
surface code which indeed like it can
correct up to 50
erasure but maybe when it's kind of
having a relatively high ratio maybe
there are other codes which can also do
something quite well like a quantum
polynomial code or other codes so but
but then maybe there's a trade-off
between what kind of codes that you want
to do with the minimum physical resource
overhead and also practically there's
also a question about the connectivity
of the hardware like how to
kind of find the code which matches best
with the hardware design
because i think for the code adams case
it's probably you're less constrained
with the nearest neighbor company
which i think it's a great opportunity
to look for like a not just nearest
neighbor coupling codes which maybe you
can have even
like a more favorable like a resource
over here
for error correction
great um shall we see if there are any
questions from the audience
[Music]
let's see
i thought somebody
maybe if you have
could you raise your hand if you
if you have a
okay um
i see there was an interesting question
from rob cook about the ions interacting
with the ripper
stage
um
okay so rob could you could you ask the
question directly
um
okay well let me read it out then it
says jeff mentioned that
two utopian ions induce immediate loss
i'm curious if there's any interesting
collisional physics
between the rydberg states and the free
ions and or photoelectrons i'm guessing
this
isn't that much of an issue else you
would add the background electric fields
yeah that's that's an interesting uh
interesting question the
um the one we can
we consider this a little bit in the in
the supplement to our paper we thought
about it some more but the one thing
that is close to being a problem that
isn't quite a problem is that when you
create this um
a tourbillon plus ion uh it's got all
these ground state atoms around it in
this array and it's and actually this
ion is not stopped it has a small uh
initial velocity because it gets the
recoil momentum from the electron that
you picked up
so now this and it's like moving at like
three and a half meters per second um
uh and
as it uh so it's moving if it's moving
in the plane of the array it could come
and you know go buy one of the other
tweezers and then the question is is it
going to you know get captured there
because actually the kind of the
scattering cross section for an ion
uh you know ground state arm is not not
that small and this is one of these
things that just turns out that a
terbium is in this kind of goldilocks
zone where if this ion was going very
much faster we wouldn't even be able to
detect it before it moved too far and
that would be the case for strontium
which has a similar recoil energy but
it's half the mass um but if it was
going slower it turns out this this
capture cross section for the neutral
atom and ion is strongly velocity
dependent and if this ion was going just
a little bit slower um then it would
actually have a pretty high probability
of colliding with this neutral atom so
this three and a half meters per second
is kind of like magical where it's going
fast enough it's not really going to
collide that collision probability is
like 10 to the minus 5 or something like
that and so you know below where it
matters um but uh but it's still slow
enough that we can detect it
perhaps i could follow up on that this
question is uh deep in the atomic
physics weeds but let me ask jeff anyway
so if i have this ion going past from um
detecting an erasure error if there's
any vector shift of the triplet p0
or vector polarizability of the triple
pc or qubit states and might defaze a
bunch of qubits in the array
yeah i didn't i didn't consider that i i
can check it my intuition is that um you
know june
junior and those guys are do well now i
was trying to but andrew loveland's
trying to stop at the 10-20 level with
these qubits in the turbine this is
really
my my guess is that it's not only not
going to not matter but by like 10
orders of magnitude but i'll i'll it's
worth checking it's worth checking
well um
excellent so i think this probably
brings us to the end of the time we have
today so um
let's see uh
jeff thanks again for for a wonderful
talk
and thanks to all the panelists for a
really great discussion
this was most enjoyable
so i i should say that
next week is our last colloquium of the
spring it's lenny suskind who will talk
about
quantum gravity and the
quantum extended
theory thesis
so
see you next week and thanks everybody
again
thank you thank you all very much